Bày tỏng nó quan sẵn, tayo ra n cũng có ngang muốn đạt được vụ thật thòn.
Tuy nhiên, nó từ nhận quan hẹa hệ bên tổng tả nước độ thử quín tự sơ sát,
và khó tự giải quyết trong thời gian,
chứ đón chả lời phòng vẫn của kinh phọng nưu,
tổng thủng mi đôi nân chăm cho biết của chiến tựa ra ngui rãn sắp két thốt,
ông nói, của chiến này đã sức gần kết thốt,
và tuy bụng sẵn nếu Mỹ không hành động như vừa qua,
thì ra n sễ có vô kí hạm nhân.
Đồng thời ấm cũng tư lộ vào nằm phản tiếp theo của thế giới sản trông khăn ngày tới.
Tôn qua, vong nằm phán kéo sài khoảng 20m tại xảy là mạ bắt,
không đạt được dụng thòn về các bánh đei thêm chốt,
như chúng chính là mạng giáo u renu của Iran,
vào quên tìm sóa tất cả tướng hẳng hẳng trị lược.
FIA Iran tổng thống mơ số và jess gain khẳng nình.
Sơn.